so the biggest story on the internet
this week is that artificially generated
girlfriends are a thing and I decided to
try and put together some of the most
important Technologies that's been
released which is AI girlfriend and chat
GPT so I realized AI will soon be able
to generate hotter than reality looking
women and then chat GPT will soon be
able to do dirty talk better and more
attentively than real girls should we be
worried about the job security of only
fans models is it only fans models that
are going to be the first are AI
displaced workforce out of the entire
lot
hey I'm I'm glad to see your concern
about the only fans uh workers Chris but
yeah it's a very interesting time in
human mating interacting with technology
and you know with dating apps and now
artificial and pornography it's an
incredible time to be studying human
mating
um I've always kind of thought that the
popularity of only fans it always
perplexed me a little bit in the first
place because you've got a unlimited
availability of free hardcore
pornography with of every type of
variety and you know male and sexual
desire is very much geared in towards
novelty seeking and different types of
variety so the fact that there was this
massive uptick in only fans uh kind of
perplexed me and I kind of began to
think that what people were looking for
from the parasocial relationship with an
only fan star that kind of personalized
content it was scratching a little bit
of a different itch they wanted that um
capturing the attention of the star and
feeling like that they were personally
interacted with with an only fan star in
a way that they didn't get from
pornography that they felt was just
produced for the masses and no real
personal connection
um so yeah you you it's kind of like a
way of competing hypotheses there and so
on the one hand men are willing to pay
for this parasocial relationship with
only fans girls for this full intimacy
rather than what they see as the
fakeness of porn but if you cross that
threshold and porn becomes like you say
it's mixed in with the mental
sophistication of an AI system that
could dirty talk in the exact kind of
fantasies that they want and will they
just go for it even more and will that
scratch that itch in the same way and
will people go full fat artificial
instead so it's it's hard to know which
direction it will kind of go but you can
kind of maybe uh see a dystopian future
where more and more men are retreating
from interacting with the mating Market
or even interacting with real people now
um and kind of a living Wholesale in
these Virtual Worlds and what that might
do to people's kind of amazing
psychology are amazing uh behavior of
even competing in The Mating Market will
they just Retreat entirely it's a it's a
dystopian kind of future
it's an interesting one man because when
you think about
what men typically want men report uh
having a greater desire for sexual
variety so during any one uh sexual
fantasy men will tend to cycle through a
number of different women if men read
erotica novels each chapter would be a
different girl whereas when women read
erotica novels the entire book is
usually one male protagonist so you have
this strange imbalance and it is I never
even thought about that why is it that
guys seem to be prepared to pay for
something which has less variety which
is one of their key drivers so it has to
be something that they get from the
single contact that they don't get from
the other side now you're right if chat
GPT was able to completely dial in the
exact type of dirty talk that you liked
with this perfectly curated AI generated
porn girl I mean it should be game over
now I was I had a debate last night in
one of our group chats that said what
only fans should do if it really wants
to become a multi-billion dollar company
is to switch from being an agency
basically an online virtual agency to
being a tech company if it can
vertically integrate itself in with what
is it that you want from your virtual
girlfriend these are all of the
different parameters of how they can
look these are all the different
parameters of how they can speak these
are all the different parameters of what
they're going to say and do and they can
basically cut out this very effortful
Creator bit in the middle that they have
to pay the Lion's Share of the money to
they could be the production company
they could be the star and they could be
the distribution medium now
I can see why that would upset some only
fans girls uh that the displacement of
you from your new job
um that has existed for a year and a
half might be upsetting but there was a
tweet from Laura Lux who said anyone who
thinks AI generated images of hot naked
women is going to ruin the only Fan's
economy for real life women has a
fundamental misunderstanding of what
only fans is people do not subscribe to
my only fans because they want to see a
random naked woman they subscribe to my
only fans because they want to see me
naked specifically based on a parasocial
connection formed by following me on
other social media platforms
yeah absolutely it's a different type of
itch being scratched and it's that idea
of capturing the attention of the porn
star it's for that brief 30 second clip
that you pay for she's focused on you
she says your name now the question then
becomes whether this AI could get
sophisticated enough to satisfy that
itch and make you feel known but humans
have this very strange kind of well not
that strange but it's called biophilia
which is defined as like an innate human
instinct to connect with nature and kind
of uh in love with being in communion
with nature and it's kind of like an
almost naturalistic fallacy in this
sense uh that you know we sometimes
think what's natural is best so examples
of this where it might not be best
placed is you could reduce a lot of
suffering by detethering yourself from
nature so I'll give you a couple of
examples and and then we can maybe talk
about the sex work and the only fans if
they were to follow that kind of Route
so in vitro meat you can now actually
cultivate meat in a lab so it's that
it's actually animal meat that you'd be
eating but no animal has to suffer or
die yet some people still feel squeamish
about this they feel actually more
squeamish about this cultivating meat in
a Petri dish even though it's real meat
and they might feel more squeamish about
that than eating a dead animal who has
had to suffer and die so that's
interesting also even childbirth so I
ran a poll a Twitter poll yesterday
asking my followers whether if you could
have a safe and reliable technology
assuming the safe and reliable
technology worked would you be in favor
of a human offspring being birthed by
artificial wounds rather than a human
female and specifically female followers
16 of them versus eight percent and 15
said no that they wouldn't be in favor
of this and if you can imagine that 300
000 women every year die during
childbirth are pregnancy you know it's
such a burden that's been on the the
female sex for so long still a massive
resistance to De tether from that
there's this biophilia kind of wanting
to be in communion with nature so if we
think about this then from the only
point of view if you defined sex work if
you see sex work as kind of harm which
many people do I'm not not particularly
one of them but then you should be a
real champion of these AI uh kind of um
AI porn or AI girlfriends but what you
might see there is a very strong
resistance from women in particular
because they could say oh we'll free up
real life women from being harmed from
being sexually objectified and at least
men will be objectifying
um unanimous
um AI sentence
exactly yeah but there's a resistance
and what might be going on there is a
bit of intersexual competition so
there's this part it is William it rears
its head yet again
oh your friendly neighborhood
evolutionary psychologist always brings
it back to intersexual competition
um but there's this interesting concept
called the horiarchy which kind of
categorizes uh humans have always paid
for sex so there's a really good article
in Colette by my friend Jerry Barnett
called the price of sex and it talks
about how cross-culturally crossed
historically humans have always paid for
sex and even when you introduce any form
of currency to chimpanzees the first
thing they do with it is pay for sex so
you know this is a a normal kind of
thing that's been going on but the
horiarchy defines that there's always a
cost for sex and at the top of a
horiarchy is a wife where you have to
pay a lot and you commit a lot of your
long-term investment at the very bottom
would be a sex worker and everything
kind of in between so there's this
strong resistance from women towards
anything that lowers the market value of
what they're selling the sex so where on
the whole exactly their fall is where
they're selling sex but everyone's
selling it
um so yeah that's interesting for that
resistance for it might be coming but
it's wild to me that even there the
resistance to a technology that would
liberate women seemingly is so resisted
well Mary Harrington wrote an article
that said AI girlfriends could liberate
men from their ancient vulnerability to
sexual desire for women now that would
roll into this a lot that if men can
find uh it's not just the emancipation
of only fans girls now back out into the
market they may need a man to support
them more likely which is one type of
intersexual competition that would be
increased but another type would be that
the desire for intimacy from Men In
general they would now be competing with
an infinitely scalable infinitely
customizable perfectly dirty chat GPT
and Dali created AI girlfriend so
there's I mean women
I I was about to say women are getting
hurt more than remember but I don't know
if they are I mean what do you think you
are one of the if not the most
preeminent in-cell researcher on the
planet
what do you think given your
understanding of a large group of
sexless men what how do you think this
is going to impact men their approach to
uh mating sexual relations
um what do you think the insult
community's got to say about this
uh yeah so a lot in many people in the
Intel community champion the idea of sex
robots or sex dolls as a kind of a a
pseudo relationship style thing and they
are hoping kind of that this is around
the corner and it's a technology will
get so good I would say maybe virtual
reality will get there faster than the
hardware of like a sex robot but the one
and you know it's a very sophisticated
AI girlfriend uh are a very
sophisticated kind sex worker would be
somewhat good for incels I think but it
doesn't scratch the itch of being
sexually selected so there's no real
status currently associated with buying
the world's best sex part it's kind of
still an underground thing you wouldn't
really be bragging about but you know
our attitudes towards sexual technology
and stigma change very fast it's not
about about 20 years ago dating apps
were weird it was weirdos who were on
them it's like oh you can't meet someone
in real life you're signing up to a
website how bizarre whereas now they're
the only game in town for human mating
so you know that would be a real leap if
we could assign status to the most
sophisticated AI girlfriend that would
be a game changer because currently men
associate status with uh female being
sexually selected
um
it's such a low ball to get an AI
girlfriend because anybody that's got
fire it would be like
um showing off to everybody that you are
on this girls only fans so well look
anybody that's got the price of a
cheeseburger per month can get on this
girl's only funds it's not a
particularly impressive or big deal uh
one of the other things that's
particularly funny and I think a number
of people are finding this ironic is
that for a long time some of the biggest
only fans creators have been using
virtual assistants and there's actual
only fans agencies who work as the girls
on the chat to generate this parasocial
relationship to really kind of squeeze
the lemon and get as much juice out out
of their followers as possible sort of
getting them sexually so excited
presumably encouraging them to donate
more money in order to be able to get
custom videos and stuff like that I mean
if you've got I was watching a video
yesterday where this girl's got 21
000 paid only fans subs and she makes
three Mill a year uh I mean in 21 000
can you just think about how many Johns
and Richards and Chris's and Williams
there are in there you know not only is
this video not for you it's it's for you
and another 150 people with your name so
I think there is definitely something
funny that
an industry that for a long time has
been really unfairly leveraging this
parasocial desire that men have to feel
special they know that this girl for the
most part isn't genuinely interested in
them but at the very least they thought
that they were having a conversation
with them they thought that they were
getting 10 seconds 30 seconds a minute
of their day and now I don't know I it's
hard to not feel a little bit uh not
Vindicated but a little bit of sort of
smoke satisfaction that girls that
perhaps had been weaponizing and
utilizing an army of Vietnamese people
to send messages dirty messages backward
and forward are now facing down what
happens if you Outsource that job to
code
mm-hmm yeah there's a really good movie
I think I talked about it last time on
the Pod Chris uh it's called her uh with
Joaquin Phoenix in it and it's basically
a about this kind of Round the Corner
dystopian future where Joaquin Phoenix's
character basically falls in love with
an AI girlfriend and at the beginning
she just talks to him a lot through his
earpiece and gets to know him supremely
well and is the best emotional support
and he genuinely falls in love with her
and they do some very creative things
where the AI system hires a biological
woman a sex worker to go and represent
her so she's actually talking to Joaquin
Phoenix's character in his head while
the biological woman is sexually
interacting him with him on a physical
level but
um spoiler alert for anyone who hasn't
seen it the kind of the end scene is he
gets frustrated and he has an argument
with the AI girlfriend and asks her how
many other people are you talking to he
discovers that she has other boyfriends
and that she talks to at the exact same
time because it's super powerful Ai and
she says 86 000 and it's just like the
scales fall from his eyes and the
hollowness of what emptiness of what he
was kind of doing
um kind of becomes apparent another
interesting selection right that's about
the selection
exactly yeah so it's kind of brought
home to him how he's just a consumer
really at the end of the day whereas you
can keep up some pretense of that and
and maybe you know like we all watch
imaginary worlds entertainment uh on
some level and it doesn't demean a kind
of a fantasy movie I watch to know that
86 million other people are watching it
so maybe that will be the level but yeah
do I see it taking the place of being
sexually selected I'm not so sure and
another interesting thing that it might
do though this um AI kind of pornography
is that it could be an example of what's
called supernormal stimuli have you
heard of supernormal stimuli Chris yes
that was the Red Dot on the beak uh
Fincher what's the guy's name
some sort of Norwegian name in Bergen
tinberg and that's it I knew it yeah so
yeah it basically describes a stimulus
that elicits a stronger response than
the response that it was evolved to give
so for example uh sugary Foods there's
so much crazy more sugary and sweets
than were revolved to actually consume
but they taste amazing to us so it's
this runaway stimulus so that might
happen with pornography because even
throughout nature the male of many
species is kind of typically easily
fooled in effect in the sexual domain so
there's the ultimate example of it is
the male Jewel Beetle which mistakenly
thinks that broken beer bottles resemble
the rear end of a female uh Beetle and
it starts to try to mate with these
empty bottles outside bars so you wonder
whether human beings interacting with
this super normal stimuli of AI
artificially created pornography will
just create a crazy skewed sense of
what's normal in terms of regular
stimuli now people make that claim about
pornography and it doesn't seem to
happen but I just wonder whether virtual
reality and that embodied cognition of
actually feeling like you're interacting
with your own body and everything
compared to just visually through
pornography I wonder whether that would
be a a leap that will actually start to
affect our amazing psychology
that would be interesting where the
upper bound of this effect actually ends
up breaking off uh I mean even if you've
got an army of Vietnamese people sending
messages and you're a hot girl that's
able to spend her three million dollars
a year on upgrading beautifying yourself
and all of the surgery and all of the
Cosmetics that you need and I think Thai
video team to make yourself look great
you're still limited by the laws of
thermodynamics right there are things
that you simply can't do whereas you
know in VR with perfectly rendered AI
girlfriends that bespoke for your
particular fetish and has already been
building this relationship with you over
chat or perhaps even through voice then
you could integrate it again in the her
style thing you're like okay we're now
going to have sex whilst Free Falling
we're now going to have sex on the sun
we're now going to have sex underwater
like all of these things that other
girls literally can't do that nobody
could do is going to present more of a
challenge when it comes to the super
normal stimuli and
I do wonder what that's going to mean is
it going to cause men to retreat from
The Mating Market into this is this
going to be sufficiently satisfying
because at the moment
both of us I think are uh at least
slightly on board with the male sedation
hypothesis of why we're not seeing a ton
of uproar amongst young men even though
they're more sexless than ever before
they don't seem to be acting out in the
way that we might expect by being
disruptive and causing problems both
societally and sexually
um however
we also know that those men the tenor
online that I see they don't seem
particularly happy about this situation
it's not like they're reveling in their
access to porn I don't think it's
actually satisfying them and you'll have
seen these sorts of comments online as
well like uh just hold on boys the sex
robots are coming soon type thing which
suggests that there is something which
is not being met thus far with the
sexual technologies that we've got now
maybe that'll never be met maybe the
desire to be selected by a mate is
actually the Crux to this and I would be
very tempted to to guess that it is that
the the the gatekeeping element the fact
that it's status full the fact that you
need both Prestige from your side to get
it and desire from the other side and
that there is a difficulty in achieving
it that is what makes it valuable it's
the same as you get given something for
free versus you pay for something you
value the thing that you paid for rather
than the thing you got for free because
it was more difficult even if the thing
you got for free was more valuable
inherently people are going to be
prepared to give away less readily
um
but there's it's definitely going to
start to push that boundary right guys
at the moment that are sexless that are
retreating into porn don't seem to be
perfectly sexually satisfied with this
titrated dose of Fitness signals that
they're getting of these reproductive
cues uh and I wonder whether
the some combination of AI generated
chatbot and VR May fix that
yeah it could and what I think we might
likely see is a very stratified kind of
mating Market where some people compete
in the natural real world for the reward
of status and then some people get kind
of drunk on the stimulation of the
virtual world and spend their time
increasing amounts of time in there you
might see people decidedly opting out of
competing in The Mating market for a
time maybe and maybe go back in and out
of it you know in my Intel research the
way they talk about in cells in with the
interviews that I've done they talk
about I always ask them when would you
know you're no longer an info and they
talk about it that they could relapse
they could actually go back to that
mindset so it's more like alcoholism of
a way of seeing the world so that idea
of you know getting
choosing to opt out of the mating market
and into the virtual one for a time
might be an option for many others but
like we say that could actually have a
pacifying effect on what are otherwise a
really destabilizing portion of society
now it seems a bit Bleak if that is the
solution but uh yeah it could be having
that pacifying effect
that's the scary thing about what this
sort of Technology does to men I think
that you know your alternative to having
this group of listless men fapping away
in their apartment with no care or
attention other than an AI girlfriend
doesn't sound great it does sound better
than having them creating roving bands
of high testosterone risk-taking guys
but only buying a tiny tiny margin right
useless manner only ever so slightly
better for society overall than
dangerous men and the only reason for
that is because we're in a time of Peace
if we're in a time of War if there was
an alien civilization coming you would
say okay let's switch off all of the
pawn let's ramp up testosterone as much
as we can let's turn off all of the
television all of the social media let's
actually get men angry in some regard
and we can just direct that anger
somewhere because if there was some sort
of large-scale requirement to Galvanize
men to move forward into something you
have a very very large subsection cohort
of the male populace that are useless
yeah absolutely another way a domain I'd
like to see this applied it could be
dating coaching so as you know I still
believe that there is space in the world
for an ethical pickup artist industry to
teach uh young men maybe perhaps young
men with autism how to navigate a very
kind of complex and dynamic mating
Market maybe learning about how to have
good interactions might make with an AI
system in virtual reality might make
people more competent in the real world
and it wouldn't have to come at the
expense of the trial and error of trying
and failing crashing and burning with
real-life women over and over again
until you learn and that would you can
simulate
you could simulate it in this AI yeah
that could be one optimistic Quest on it
well the the
precise reason that AI generated
sexbot girlfriends are low status
is the exact same reason why they make
the perfect training ground for you to
do well at trying to chat them up
yep it's like a yeah practice there in
the the training ground and then go into
the real world and the collateral damage
of real-life women having incompetence
kind of come on attempts uh part of
men's learning uh is mitigated away no
one suffers in this development of
competent men
except for whoever has to read the code
on the back end of all of these failed
attempts from uh an unfortunate young
guys trying to trying their different
pickup lines but yeah I mean if you were
able to model effectively a woman's
preferences you know embed some
neuro-linguistic programming in there uh
some body language cues some other you
know all even be able to adapt what
clothes you're wearing how you're
sitting the sort of all of that stuff if
you could do that it is kind of strange
right when when we look at mating it's
one of the most important things that
people do like where you live what you
do and who you do it with the three big
questions that everybody has to answer
in life
people before they go out to play
weekend kickball have a practice session
right they have a practice session where
they're playing in a sandbox that aren't
very high stakes they're around a
supportive group of people or perhaps
they're on their own I mean you can go
into a batting cage and you can just
have literally a robot throw a ball at
you and all that you need to do is
practice your swing I'm going to work on
this part I'm going to work on that part
you could video it yourself you could
watch that training footage back I bet
that there is AI uh software that will
analyze your swing automatically for you
and tell you why you're falling off the
same thing would happen I used to play
cricket for a long time I know that you
played Gaelic football all of these
things in order to become good at any
Pursuit especially one that's got high
pressure and you don't get a second
chance at
you need to actually spend some time
practicing it the problem is that most
men don't get the opportunity to
practice because they are the high wire
Act of actually practicing is so
terrifying that they don't ever get to
play around with it I dude that would be
one of the most hopeful ways to actually
a very a very surprisingly hopeful way
to look at this problem
yeah and it actually annoys me when
people kind of uh pretend that the
amazing Market is so opaque that you
can't learn anything about it and uh it
tends to be the people who are already
mated or sexually successful anyway that
they just pretend oh it just happens
when it happens stop thinking about it
bro it'll just happen and infills tear
their hair out when men or women say
this to them because it doesn't happen
without happening I actually had a
friend recently introduced me to his new
girlfriend and both of them they're in
the in the room told me I don't know how
it happened because neither of us were
trying for it to happen I wasn't trying
to go out with her and she wasn't trying
to get with me and I'm like well how did
it happen then you know so you have to
actually consciously try it doesn't just
happen out of nowhere but yeah there's
no training ground for men or even this
idea of learning about it is always
framed as misogynistic and uh it needn't
be I think it it could be and if you
could mitigate away women's kind of
discomfort through an AI system that
would be an Optimum Mystic Twist on this
but the pushback to that I can imagine
is people saying well look at the way
men use porn now they're not using it to
learn about how to please women in the
bedroom fair enough but I think an AI
system actually I think there would be a
hunger for men to actually learn how to
be competent lovers in the bedroom and
uh you know that there is a desire to do
that and I think you could learn from an
AI system and more than you can from
watching pornography which is only
geared towards entertainment I don't
think there's a real market for
educational pornography and but even men
learning about how to please women is
sometimes framed as misogynistic I read
a cosmo article a few years ago where it
talked about men enjoy giving women
orgasms and this is a problem it's like
what why is this a problem it's because
if men enjoy pleasing women it's bad it
strips of the value we should do it out
of just Duty like oh oh okay I'm
supposed to to lambast myself I'll get
the cat of nine tails out and I'll Whip
myself before I before I actually get
cracking yeah I mean that's the fact
that someone like whatever Cosmopolitan
or l a Cosmopolitan is is genuinely
idiotic now it's so moronic some of the
Articles coming out of that that uh
uh Louise Perry found how to sleep with
him and not patch feels oh how to
disembody yourself from the single most
sacred act that you can do in your life
oh yeah really great work there creating
freedom for your female readership Cosmo
um but they the the idea that it's um I
I could imagine that there is something
alluring especially to a a gen Zed Cosmo
type writer or editor that my idea of
them in their in their sort of hell hole
that they work in
um of a man who does do things out of
Duty because it's a man who's incredibly
pliable right it's a man who is
absolutely no threat he's got no agency
or sovereignty he's got no upward
Mobility or ability to enact anything
really of his own whereas a man that
does something maybe even almost out of
fear keeping the the female uh
physiology in a black box like this is
something that they're not supposed to
be able to do because if he could do
that with you then maybe he could do
that with somebody else but if he can
only do do it with you and you don't
really actually maybe tell them quite
what's going on I mean it's a horribly
un healthy way to categorize this uh but
dude I would be I think that the the
training ground and the reason that the
training ground thing works
um like what would you call it like uh
yeah like the girlfriend sandbox yeah um
the reason that it works is that there
is still status
waiting for you on the other side of
completing it because if you practice
either sex or chatting up a girl in VR
what you know is that on the other
eventually down the road this may lead
to something which already has cultural
status attributed to it um so that would
be cool but look dude I mean I an oddly
very white pilled way to round out a
discussion to do with this I do think
that what happens with only fans over
the next
two years will generally be fascinating
I think that the Laura looks comment
about the parasocial relationship is a
total cope because if the AI can do
dirty talk it can already create the uh
like organic social media platform
content that would generate the
parasocial relationship in the first
place uh the only thing that you're
going to be able to do is maybe gatekeep
you could perhaps make an entire
platform that was
um no AIS allowed that would have a very
strict verification process that girls
would have to go through so that you
know that you're actually talking to at
least
the virtual assistant of a girl that
exists in the real world as opposed to
just code what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
[Music]